-Here at "The Tonight Show,"
we love songs,
and we especially love songs
written by our audience members
in under an hour.
It's time for "Battle of
the Instant Songwriters."
Here we go.
-♪ Something song,
and I'm singing a song ♪
♪ And I'm writing a song
about another song ♪
-Welcome to "Battle of
the Instant Songwriters."
Now, before the show,
we went through our audience
and picked out people --
two people --
who said that
they were musicians.
[ Laughter ]
We gave them each
a made-up song title --
You don't have to be,
but you said that you were,
so we'll see if they were.
Now, we gave them
an hour to write
an original song
based on that title.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage a minute ago.
Oh, two guitarists.
They're going for it.
All right, here we go.
I can't wait to see
what they came up with.
Let's meet them right now.
Come on over, guys!
Our contestants, welcome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello.
Nice to see you.
Welcome. Thank you.
Welcome.
Yeah!
Welcome to the show!
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you.
-Let's start with
contestant number one.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name is Victoria Skie,
and I am from New Jersey.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Victoria Skie -- great name.
What was the --
what was the title of the song
that you were given?
-The title was
"I Still Don't Understand NFTs."
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
That's very -- That's very good.
I like that.
I can't wait
to hear this song, yeah.
I'm just figuring it out myself.
What instrument
will you be playing?
The guitar?
-Guitar.
-Yeah, perfect.
All right, go get ready.
And whenever you're set...
Get comfortable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now this is a big deal.
You can scoot over here,
if you'd like.
Yeah.
Ladies and gentlemen, here to
perform the world premiere
of the soon-to-be classic,
"I Still Don't Understand NFTs,"
it's Victoria Skie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Since I was a little girl ♪
♪ I've loved to doodle hearts
and swirls ♪
♪ And draw my family
like ugly sticks ♪
♪ Yeah, they were never
any good ♪
♪ Oh, but now we live
in a different world ♪
♪ And my uncle old me he thinks
I could get rich ♪
♪ Real quick ♪
♪ It's something 'bout crypto ♪
♪ Went over my head ♪
♪ Guess these monkeys
ain't jumping on any more beds ♪
♪ Now they're worth
a million dollars ♪
♪ Oh, I wish that could be me ♪
♪ But I still
don't understand NFTs ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Why can't we
just screenshot them? ♪
♪♪
♪ What currency
even buys them? ♪
♪ I guess
they're just untouchable ♪
♪ And something
'bout non-fungible ♪
♪ But I still
don't understand NFTs ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Man, that's not bad.
That's -- yeah.
Victoria Skie, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was incredible.
That was phenomenal.
Thank you so much.
-Yeah.
-Good luck, buddy.
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Contestant number two,
what is your name,
and where are you from, pal?
-My name is Asa Daniels,
and I'm from Long Island.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, good man.
We love Long Island.
Thanks, Asa Daniels.
Great names.
What -- What title
were you given today?
-Sure. They gave me
"Batman Spoilers."
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
Be very careful with this song,
yeah, 'cause we don't
want to hear any "Batman"
spoilers, but -- you might.
You might.
[ Laughter ]
Wow. Have you seen the new
"Batman" movie?
-I have not.
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm guessing.
-Perfect.
Yeah, this is a perfect song
for you, "Batman Spoilers."
And you're playing the guitar,
as well?
-Yeah, that's right.
In my band,
I play guitar, and I sing.
-I love that, bud.
-Later tonight.
-Let's do it.
Let's go for it.
Yeah, go get ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A very talented audience.
Come on over here, pal.
♪♪
And I just want
to remind everyone,
he has not seen
the new "Batman" movie.
[ Laughter ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
get ready for the world premiere
of "Batman Spoilers,"
by Asa Daniels!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ It's Wednesday night ♪
♪ I'm just hanging
with my friends ♪
♪ Someone says,
"Let's go and see 'Batman'" ♪
♪ Maybe they'll have cameos ♪
♪ From all the
past movies like ♪
♪ Bale and Keaton
and my boy George Clooney ♪
♪ I've got some spoilers
of my own to tell ♪
♪ Joker joined the Girl Scouts ♪
♪ And he's got
some cookies to sell ♪
♪ Alfred plays kickball
with Commissioner Gordon ♪
♪ And I heard
it's now a musical ♪
♪ And it's starring
James Corden ♪
♪ Catwoman blows
all of her money ♪
♪ Buying cans of Fancy Feast ♪
♪ Riddler's riddles
are just Wordle ♪
♪ And he breaks up
Batman's streak ♪
♪ Bruce Wayne
is rich and famous ♪
♪ He's got a lot of gadgets ♪
♪ Sounds like
he's just Elon Musk ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
That's fantastic!
[ Laughs ]
Batman is Elon Musk!
Not bad.
That was awesome!
Oh, my gosh.
Fantastic.
Give it up once again.
Asa Daniels, right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Asa Daniels.
And now it is time
to see who won,
so we're gonna let our great
audience decide the winner.
Was it Victoria Skie?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or was it Asa Daniels?
Victoria Skie is the winner,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Ding! ]
♪♪
Victoria, you are going home
with $1,000 in an envelope
and a notebook --
a "Tonight Show" notebook
so you can write more songs.
-Thank you so much.
-You were very talented.
Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-Hey.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, no one goes home
empty-handed.
You will also be going home
with $1,000
and a "Tonight Show" notebook.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much.
-Both of you guys.
Give it up for your two new
instant songwriters,
right there!
Very talented.
Funny. It was awesome.
Thank you so much.